this feels like what mark webb wanted to
do but couldn't do it
we've got to make this cool he's got a
skateboard to call away though i want to
deal with spider-man's angst and his
depression and feeling like an outsider
having struggles with who am i really
can you throw rhino in there flipping
continues today spider-man lotus full
trailer gonna do a reaction of this this
is something i've heard about for
several months a lot of people have been
telling me about this uh little fan made
project i don't even want to say a
little it's pretty ambitious to my
understanding last night heavy spoilers
paul was like dude you gotta check out
this trailer and i said shut up you
british twit
and then
that's how i talked to him he
appreciated that yeah i hope you're
watching paul
no no he's always on the lookout for
good things to cover sure enough all of
my like instagram and twitter so many
message requests just kept coming in
about this specific trailer i've
literally heard nothing but good things
about it i know some stuff i'm not we're
not that well informed on everything
obviously this will be the first trailer
we're actually gonna watch for any
actual video footage so here it goes
it's from the channel
gjknob link in the description box and
pin comment
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
me down
come here
[Music]
don't think of this as a goodbye too at
all
think of it more as a checking in tape
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
just checking in to say hi
[Music]
and then i miss you
god damn it's just so heartbreaking yeah
very peter centric
whoever he thinks i am
i'm not
you've seen the headlines
figure it
that little out in there has looked up
to you his entire
epic
you are his hero
so please
give him something to believe in
wow this is so personal yeah
we all lost something
but i think we gained something too
i will always be spider-man
not because i want to
because i have to
i love you
[Music]
that was so moving
[Music]
i was all moving
not bad
yeah you gotta have your gobby
gotta have your gobby in there
absolutely a whole lot of
drama
for peter parker this takes place a
little bit after gwen's death
obviously because i'm so analytical i'm
so observant and only the few can pick
up on such great detail with me this
takes place a little bit after gwen's
death and i believe that boy is like
diagnosed with cancer
something terminal something terminal i
love the tone poem quality to it it's a
tale of
grief being able to find your sense of
self-worth again it feels more
spider-man
some of what we've got in recent years
with the mcu yeah i've never
i think ever heard anyone say that about
a fan film based off a major franchise
especially not in the past handful of
years yeah so we're not getting like the
fun quippiness or him dealing with what
it's like to be in high school and
balance that and have the financial
struggles is that demonstrated in this
trailer no there's a lot of things about
spider-man but this feels very focused
pivotal for this man's journey here and
it feels appropriate to have this family
film like do i believe andrew garfield
is going to be in spider-man no way home
i firmly believe that however you know
like when you look at the events of
amazing spider-man 2 the death of gwen
stacy in comics is a very monumental
moment what was a major trajectory for
peter parker i love how this is dealing
with an identity crisis situation for
him you know like that's that was the at
the time the love of his life who he
lost
and uh as i imagine that green goblin
moment as much as there's a tease there
i feel like this movie might be
bookended with that like the start maybe
a flashback that shows the death of gwen
stacy involving green goblin and then
perhaps at the end too when coming to
confrontation with green goblin but i
like how peter parker focused it is with
him essentially his going through the
darkest time of grief unable to accept
this it's almost as if he's like dealing
with this impostor syndrome it's pretty
much what we saw in the last five
minutes of amazing spider-man 2 but
really focused taking its time
allowing you to deal with the depression
that comes with it and the angst i like
the idea of like focusing on a personal
relationship with this this boy who
looks up to him but he doesn't view
himself in the way how some of the
public like this little boy i see in
this kid who's dying his like
make-a-wish foundation type of deal is
just want to meet my hero but he doesn't
feel like he is that hero
it is a it is an interesting uh
dichotomy hero com complex you know yeah
yeah absolutely because i mean it's that
nice i think it makes for a nice
compliment to have the story of him
grieving over gwen stacy pitted kind of
against this backdrop of him trying to
inspire this child who he can't dump all
the realities of life onto i believe
these are story lines that do i mean
obviously with gwen stacy but the story
with the little boy is also like a comic
book and cartoon you know storyline it's
called the kid who collected spider-man
or collects spider-man i actually saw
the animated series episode as a kid
because that was when i saw what this is
about i was like oh wow interesting i
that was not the poll i had expected i
haven't read the comic but uh yeah and
so having those go together
that idea that he is in such a grief
state and then has to take on this
almost in that state it can feel like a
burden to have to inspire somebody and
to have to play to the best of yourself
and your image and all that stuff for
the sake of someone else believe me i
know absolutely if anybody can relate to
this trailer i am the little boy
you are peter parker
that's right man i'm so sorry about
olivia
is seeing peter grieve over you know a
death of some kind of something you know
we've seen in the movies but this kind
of touching quality that it seems to
exude i mean i feel like there is a
hazardous element where you could maybe
go too much into being you know dramatic
and melancholy but if they hit the mark
i think that could be really touching
you'll have to keep the bigger more you
know cg enhanced action elements in the
fringes for something like this and to
have such sort of an emotionally
resonant story of a personal stripe on
one side with gwen and his grief over
gwen and then this unrelated story by
the comics but that also seems like it's
perfectly uh in tune in terms of a
sentimental standpoint i think it's
really clever yeah it's got that cool
like indie drama vibe it feels like what
mark webb wanted to do
we've got to make this cool he's got a
skateboard to call away though i want to
deal with spider-man's angst and his
depression and feeling like an outsider
and having struggles with who am i
really can you throw rhino in there can
we make him james dean when we're at it
this is the thing it's like these fan
made films and and shorts and trailers
and all that stuff are inspiring for
that very fact is like because the
comics get so broad with like oh we can
do this approach and that approach and
anything's possible i feel like the fan
man films are where you feel that spirit
more reliably
yeah i think it's also shot really well
i love like the close framing on
everything it feels so intimate i love
like the gritty shots at the very top of
it this feels painful i feel like i'm
watching who directed blue valentine
derek sukkoffer
with derrick
scene friends i think so he's directing
the wolf man that's going to be a really
uplifting film i do think there's
something with the with the whole like
recording that's that's the thing people
do as part of their grief like recording
your feelings on tape is a thing that
people do in real life uh but i i think
there is a comic where he does that oh
yep you can can't pull the comic at all
i'm not brain but i i believe there is a
comic book spider-man tapes
or something like that
if i had to have a concern to address is
that sometimes with films that are this
much of a mood piece it can feel like
what you were talking about with the
concern is that it beats you over the
head with it that you become kind of
numb to the pain there's a lack of gray
here where the point at which the
melancholy can become too much and start
to become melodramatic rather than
touching yeah because in order to feel
the mellow drama
you have to have a little bit more of
that nuanced life and maybe they'll come
in the form of the the interaction with
the little boy
where he webs out the cancer
right
just pulls the two verses directly out
ah that would be i've never seen that in
a superhero movie so i would be dazzling
spider-man maybe if it is the mark webb
one he has the the magic blood yeah it's
heaven
you just inject the boy
no i got a hobgoblin on my hands
your dna is in the spider
no this is amazing i mean the fact that
this is fan made and it feels this
personal and the amount of support
rallying around this
is in it of itself a massive
accomplishment so gj khan up you should
feel
overwhelmed with gratitude now let's
just hope your movie turns out actually
good
because right now you got a lot of
support and i feel like you're going to
do an excellent job
all right guys well please if you
haven't seen this trailer in full screen
if you happen to be most of the time if
you're here for a reaction you have
already seen the original video but if
we are one of the few who are
introducing you to this trailer please
go subscribe to the actual channel
there's a link in the pin comment and
the description box and i'll give the
actual trailer of you because they 100
deserve it and they need to support as
much as possible they're doing things
that would i wish i could do but
unfortunately john's holding me back in
life i am from my own self-motivation ed
to your sean buddy i don't get the
reference play video games with me in
the shed
shawn of the dead
what does shaun of the dead have to do
with this you know it's a reference that
fit the thing we've been filming for 18
minutes
[Music]